diving into a whole new level of
intimacy people have been getting it
together online for a while now but
thanks to virtual reality headsets the
experience has never felt more real
according to journalist Yankee Nyang
ssin the latest sex tech is too much for
some
it's done the foul fun confer example
you can have a virtual woman right in
front of you when she leans in for a
kiss it feels so close that many of the
people I've tried it with have
instinctively ripped off the headset the
cyber sex industry is pitched at the
young adult market two-thirds of men in
Germany regularly consume porn online
compared to one in five women
psychologist Matthias plan sees nothing
wrong with it but says it can become
addictive the think Hathorne Indies done
there are people who devote a great part
of their day to cyber sex and have
withdrawal symptoms if they're not
online mr. Mukesh cut harden online
design in cyber sex soo Kwang soo Myung
Moon si le bendiga this can have a
negative impact on their daily lives as
well as their professional and private
lives Robotnik's dutch company kero is
ahead of the game the company makes what
it bills as interactive pleasure
products for long-distance relationships
devices that communicate with each other
using teledildonics technology employee
Alex Lecrae explains the pole is like
any other vibrator except the outside is
touch sensitive under the skin there are
some rings that measure whether you're
down here or up here to go in and out
the Onyx then responds to where it's
being touched by compressing one of its
rings once turned on the devices
automatically connect by a Bluetooth or
online if the distance is large Hiro was
launched in spring 2015 its target
market includes people in long distance
relationships ready students Jess and
Shawn met in Rotterdam like many other
young people they're completely open to
the idea of computer-aided sex for them
communicating online is already the norm
we snapchat each other constantly we do
all sorts of like you know we use every
other sort of media form whereas this
allows us to why not be able to reach
that way Kira uses tactile data
technology two years ago condom
manufacturer dierickx opted for the same
approach when it launched the app
funderwear its underwear that connects
to a smartphone app you can control the
vibrations yourself with a smart phone
as a remote or pair with your partner's
smartphone is the technology a set of
Angelica this technology is designed for
you simultaneously by a couple so they
can share a sexual experience even if
they're apart there's a social
communicative component in our d feared
by puzzle and that's generally something
people with cyber sex addictions don't
have when they consume porn online if
they're not sharing the experience with
a real life person thanks to
teledildonics Jeff and Sean don't have
to settle for celibacy when they go
their separate ways to university not
exactly anyway nothing beats real
threats real human contact real skin to
skin contact like nothing will ever beat
that there'll be nothing that I can even
fathom like in the future that will be
able to in moderation cyber sex can be
enjoyable and liberating whether
explored by solo users or couples
digital sex for Millennials shift says
the future looks exciting